[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter le
créateur des Hunger Games en personne le
doyen Kaska hypother
je vous ai tous réunis ici pour la 10e
cérémonie annuelle de la moisson durant
laquelle nous choisirons deux enfants de
chaque district pour combattre jusqu'à
la mort lors d'un Hunger Games
il y a eu un changement cette année
en tant que mentor monsieur snow votre
rôle est de transformer ses enfants en
bête de scène part en survivant que va
faire mon mentor à part m'offrir des
roses de mon mieux pour prendre soin de
toi tu veux vraiment prendre soin de moi
dans cette arène commence par croire que
je peux gagner
je suis Lucky flickrman le tout premier
présentateur des Hunger Games profitez
du spectacle
profitez du spectacle
c'est on ne peut plus facile
alimenter la peur de devenir une proie
et vous verrez à quelle vitesse on
devient un prédateur vous verrez à
quelle vitesse la civilisation disparaît
[Musique]
on nous tous il y a de la bonté
naturelle
on peut décider de franchir la ligne qui
nous sépare du mal ou pas
vous entendez ça mon garçon
c'est le bruit qui fait la neige
en tombant
comme ces merveilleux d'avoir la chance
d'assister à la dernière prestation de
quelqu'un
il ne s'agit pas seulement de gagner la
seule chose qui compte c'est gagner
ce sont les choses auxquelles nous
donnons le plus qui nous détruisent